here with reactions of the night's
breaking news and opening monologue Fox
News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka and attorney Victoria
tun Singh
full disclosure she has done some legal
work for me in the past and I am proud
to be a friend of both of them let's
start with you Victoria a lot to break
down here tonight listen Sean since last
December my husband Joe digenova and I
have been saying that there was a brazen
plot to clear Hillary Clinton and to
frame Donald Trump if he became
president and now we're seeing that plot
unravel this Brennan clapper and I'm
gonna say it the Obama White House
targeted people on Donald Trump's
foreign policy team and the professor
they tried to get two of them Carter
page and my client Sam Clovis who I hope
will be with us sometime next week
and they didn't bite but then they found
the weak link a 20-some year old George
papadopolis and here's what's been
reported and it's really when you think
about it and I started researching it
today George papadopolis is told by a
professor with close ties to the Kremlin
that the Russians have Hillary's emails
that's in April in May George finds
himself at a bar in London and some
gorgeous blonde comes up and starts
buying him drinks my goodness and then
she introduces him to her good friend
the Australian ambassador and somehow
the conversation goes to Hillary
Clinton's War wait hearsay hearsay
hearsay is not admissible in court
you're the attorney correct Victoria
yeah but that doesn't matter here for
goodness sakes he's just saying that
that he's just talking about Hillary's
there's there's a term for John it's
called honey trapping this is classic
spy agency CIA I used to be chief
counsel for the Senate Intelligence
Committee
this is classic spying technique honey
trapping using the lure of sex to get
somebody to open up a balloon and and
then oh now your body wait for the 25
grand himself to the Clinton
by millions of the Clinton Foundation
and then to use that flimsy information
to start an entire surveillance and
investigation of the Trump campaign just
boggles the mind
sebastien worker we need to put this in
perspective Sean Victoria is absolutely
right when it came to what was done
operationally but but what is this in
the most concise terms this is the first
time in US history that we have had
industrial scale political espionage
during a presidential campaign our
nation was founded in a rejection of the
capricious usurpation of power that's
why we had the Revolutionary War now
it's happening in the Obama
administration at the highest level of
the intelligence community we created
these systems to detect apprehend and
prosecute Soviet spies Nazis and
terrorists not people who simply have a
different political persuasion the
president was right he was spied upon
he was surveilled they tried to entrap
his people and frame him you know and we
are just at the beginning of our IR
sharyl Attkisson today she said we have
unveiled less than two percent correct
of the real corruption we still have a
masking we still have a rigged
investigation we have spies in the Trump
campaign we have Hillary working with
Russian lies against the American people
Russian lies bought and paid for FISA
Court abuse to the point where they lied
to four judges where does it end
Victoria well I hope it's not ending
words starting we're starting to unravel
and peel back this onion and god bless
these FBI agents who want to come
forward we were told that everybody in
the FBI just loved James Comey well it
appears that there's some that want to
see him indicted and I hope that happens
all right thank you both appreciate your
insight